[Aplausos]
17 años 17 años estuve dentro del
sistema educativo
me enseñaron muchísimas cosas
no siempre me enseñaron a aprender en
muchas ocasiones me enseñaron a
memorizar pero bueno pasaron todos los
años me enseñaron todos los ríos de mi
país y nunca fui a pescar
me enseñaron el trinomio cuadrado
perfecto 7 horas semanales durante toda
la vida yo creo
y yo creo que yo soy uno de esos del 80%
de las personas en el mundo que nunca
más uso el trinomio cuadrado perfecto
cuando se fue de la escuela
me enseñaron todas las capitales del
mundo pero nunca me dijeron
como juntar dinero para poder conocerlas
la verdad es que cuando yo estaba en el
colegio intuye y sentía que no me
estaban enseñando el lo que yo tenía que
aprender han pasado 30 años que salí del
sistema educativo y sigue siendo
absolutamente igual
con el tiempo perdone perdone el
graduarme sin saber las cosas más
importantes de la vida como por ejemplo
aprender a ser feliz
cómo gestionar tus emociones y tu
inteligencia emocional
como trabajar en equipo como hablar en
público
finanzas personales como usa una tarjeta
de crédito como comprar tu primer coche
son cosas que 30 años después el sistema
educativo aún no enseña
cosas claves como aprender a comer y
saber qué es una proteína un
carbohidrato cómo funciona la azúcar en
tu cerebro tampoco lo enseñan
no te enseña cómo funciona la biología
de tu cuerpo no enseña cómo funciona tu
cerebro
y pasan los años y pasan los años y el
sistema educativo no cambia
y el mundo es otro todo ha cambiado en
el mundo - el sistema educativo y hoy
los chicos se gradúan sin saber cómo
sobrevivir en la vida
su carrera empieza
cuando salen al mundo a la vida y su
verdadero aprendizaje lo hacen cuando
salen al mundo pudiendo ellos salir
preparados con práctica no solo con
teoría no con materia de rellenos sino
con toda la información que necesitamos
saber hoy para antes de graduarnos ser
emprendedores y ser dueños de nuestros
negocios porque eso sí el sistema
educativo es buenísimo enseñarte a ser
empleado
después de 30 años perdone al sistema
educativo hasta
hace 5 años mi hija de 15 años
se quejaba todo el día de dolores
estomacales
cuando la sacamos del colegio porque
ella gritaba en el piso tirar al piso y
decimos que tiene esta niña la llevamos
a muchos hospitales a muchos doctores se
nos hacía rarísimo que no encontraban
que tenía
y daniela mi hija que hoy tiene 20 años
recién cumplidos ella a los 15 años no
podía soportar
los dolores intestinales que tenía
primero nos dijeron que era cáncer luego
nos dijeron que una enfermedad
degenerativa no saben el doctor me dijo
jürgen no mires por favor en el internet
de qué trata esta enfermedad que lo
quise saliendo
y me puse a llorar
ella no podía al colegio por los niveles
de estrés tan elevado que tenía
ella no pudo al colegio porque la
profesora le decía cosas que le hacían
sentir mal ella no podía el colegio
porque ella sentía que era la única
burra que no podía aprender matemáticas
siendo que ella a los 15 años era una
artista en forma pintando cuadros
haciendo fotografías y haciendo vídeos
semiprofesionales
después de toda esa vuelta que nos
fuimos eeuu nos fuimos a colombia nos
fuimos a méxico para ver realmente que
tenía daniela y los nosotros estamos
absolutamente estresados y afectados
porque nos esperábamos lo peor un doctor
nos dijo que ella se toma esta pastilla
que es una cámara fotográfica que se
llama el cam que toma 500.000
fotografías porque ya le habían hecho
endoscopia colonoscopia y quedaban 6
metros por investigar que tenía el
intestino
al final del estudio nos dijo
ella no tiene nada serio ese es un
problema netamente estrés y psicológico
averigüen qué le pasó en el colegio y
ahí empezó a la historia
cuando empezamos a investigar como ella
se relacionaba con sus compañeros con
sus profesores con el sistema con las
materias una niña absolutamente
responsable la cual no le entraba la
matemáticas como no me entraba a mí
porque no le gustaba encontrar mucho
sentido porque ella es artista y hoy es
un artista muy reconocida para su edad
se nos hizo muy interesante entender que
uno de los mejores colegios de la
florida
una vez más ella fue afectada por el
sistema educativo
veronica mi esposa y yo decidimos
investigar en eeuu y realmente los
colegios estaban realmente ayudando a
los niños o estaban afectando y nos
dimos cuenta que hasta los mejores
colegios están afectando profundamente a
los niños
decidimos emprender un proyecto
increíble nos entrenamos durante tres
años para ser no grafía antropología ya
sabíamos cómo hacerlo pero realmente
queríamos un trabajo muy ético y muy
profesional y nos fuimos a conocer los
mejores sistemas educativos del mundo
según los exámenes y sant que lo único
que evalúan principalmente es la lectura
la compresión y las matemáticas vuelve
el problema
la gente aprende a leer comprende poco
sabe matemáticas pues no le enseñan a
ser feliz
etcétera etcétera etcétera entonces
dijieron finlandia singapur corea del
sur son los mejores sistemas educativos
del mundo y como yo a mí no me gusta que
me cuenten agarramos el avión y nos
lanzamos para hacer un documental
educativo para regalárselos lo pueden
ver todos ustedes después de las grandes
conclusiones de haber visitado 17 países
haber investigado los mejores sistemas
educativos y los peores sistemas
educativos el nombre le cayó perfecto un
crimen llamado educación así de sencillo
ahora déjenme contarles por qué se llama
un crimen llamado educación este año
corea del sur se convirtió el mejor
sistema educativo del mundo
y fuimos a hablar con los chicos y a
conocer las escuelas y las mejores
universidades en seúl
50% de los surcoreanos tienen
pensamientos suicidas es tan serio el
problema por el estrés escolar y la
excesiva y estúpida competencia que
tienen los chicos entre ellos que
pierden todos sus amigos porque tu peor
enemigo
es tu amigo que está estudiando contigo
y está en tu salón por qué pasa él y
sobrevive o te mueres tú dentro del
sistema
donde la competencia es infernal
corea del sur tiene departamentos
completos antisuicidio encore al suelo
pueden ver en nuestro documental hay
terapia anti suicidio para estudiantes
los meten ataúdes para que sepan lo
serio que suicidarse
los barrotes de los dormitorios de la
mejor universidad en seúl
están por todas las ventanas de los
chicos en lanza por las ventanas y
decíamos los coreanos deben ser bien
locos entonces nos fuimos a singapur y
las cosas eran bien parecidas y bueno
fuimos a finlandia
y los niños chiquitos son super felices
se ven felices cuando son adolescentes
ya no son tan felices cuando están en
universidad
se convierte una sociedad que dice ser
uno de mejores sistemas educativos del
mundo y son de los países con más
suicidio más depresión y más drogas
y mucha gente dice es que con ese clima
cualquiera tú te vas a noruega te vas a
suecia y no es lo mismo de qué sirve que
un sistema educativo sea maravilloso si
nunca nos han enseñado a ser felices a
querernos ya sonreír en finlandia yo me
paré en una esquina durante 14 minutos y
nadie me volvió a ver pasaron más de
2000 personas a lo mío era una entrada
del metro
y nadie me sonrío ni nadie miró ni idea
digo quién es este loco es como si era
un póster lo pueden ver en el documental
después llegamos a latinoamérica
estuvimos en mexico
viendo la corrupción del sistema
educativo donde me vendían un título
enfrente a una cuadra de la secretaria
de educación donde te pedían un 50% de
anticipo y el otro 50% de anticipo te lo
daban cuando salía el código en la sep
un crimen llamado educación donde uno
puede comprar un título en todas partes
del mundo en los países corruptos uno
puede comprar un título lo que uno puede
comprar es que aparezca en la sep
señores
la mafia tiene totalmente secuestrado el
sistema educativo es el gran negocio de
miles de personas y gobernantes
despertemos esta realidad porque si el
mundo no cambia
si la gente no cambia nunca podremos ver
menos corrupción menos ignorancia menos
injusticia y menos chicos estresados
porque da risa porque los adultos al día
de hoy dicen el niño está estresado como
estresado si es niño por favor un estrés
infantil y un estrés una adolescente es
tres veces más potente emocionalmente
hablando que el estrés de un adulto
el problema es muy serio
y no veo una luz de cambio a pesar que
hay instituciones educativas que existan
intentando hacer el cambio pero el gran
enemigo es el mismo sistema nosotros
tenemos que cambiar el sistema nosotros
tenemos que tomar el sistema y volver a
ser todo un nuevo sistema educativo que
beneficie y haga mucho más respetuoso el
mundo y menos ignorante es por eso que
yo les quiero compartir a todos ustedes
las cosas que he visto que aprendido
después de viajar a tantos países para
que ustedes
puedan sobrevivir ante un sistema
educativo fallido
lo primero los papás tienen que entender
una cosa porque tienen un rol
fundamental dentro del juego recoge a tu
hijo del colegio en la primaria y en la
secundaria todos los días tienes 15
minutos 1 2 3 15 minutos para detectar
su cara para ver si fue una víctima de
bullying de depresión de golpes de
abusos
y de muchas otras cosas más si tú llegas
a las 8 de la noche y tu hijo sale a las
dos y cuarto nunca vas a poder detectar
eso porque después de cuatro o cinco
horas ya no se puede leer su cara de la
misma forma
los chicos hoy sufren de bullying hoy
los chicos en la escuela cuando tienen
mucha energía
los recetan con ritalina les dan
medicamentos para controlar su energía
haciendo que la energía es la magia del
liderazgo la energía es la magia del
aprendizaje si no tienes energía potente
jamás vas a lograr con la vida y en el
colegio te médica
si tienes atención dispersa eso yo le
llamo un crimen nunca permitas que a tu
hijo lo médic en
en su país más del 35 por ciento de los
niños son medicados para controlar la
atención dispersa
lo segundo que le recomiendo
el colegio es un pedazo de la historia
el colegio te puede dar cosas muy
maravillosas pero debe cambiar la parte
social ahí está
la parte relación ante humana ahí está
intrínsicamente no te enseñan cómo
hacerlo pero aprendes porque vas al
colegio
las competencias blancas blandas las
habilidades prácticas de la vida son
fundamentales para ser alguien en la
vida
estudian en internet vengan estos
eventos increíbles pónganse a pensar
todo el conocimiento toda la cultura y
todo el beneficio que ha dejado en el
mundo solamente por charlas como esta
porque la ven miles y miles de personas
busquen respuestas en los líderes
busquen respuestas en el youtube vale
mucho la pena hacerlo hoy las respuestas
de la vida no están dentro del colegio
pero si están en las redes
lo tercero jamás jamás pienses que una
calificación
define quién es tu hijo
yo fui pésimo al himno alumno en
calificaciones una calificación jamás
define quién es el niño en ese momento y
menos en el futuro y la mejor prueba de
esto es que los que sacan las mejores
calificaciones no siempre son los
mejores en la vida ni los más felices
nunca permitan que las calificaciones
definan quién va a ser tu hijo y no los
'stress en tercero los exámenes un
examen lo único que hace es hacerte
sentirte un ciudadano de segunda
te hace sentir burro
te hace sentir inferior los exámenes
están siendo mucho daño a nuestros hijos
sin embargo si no podemos quitar los
exámenes por lo menos enseñarle a tus
hijos que nos afecten psicológicamente
por los exámenes la gente dice que el
colegio enseña disciplina y por eso es
tan bueno si eso fuera cierto pues el
90% de nosotros éramos disciplinados lo
que te enseña la disciplina es el
deporte profesional con reglas
profesionales y cómo alimentarte todos
los días porque si vas a comer 56 veces
al día ahí se define tu disciplina que
vas a comer que vas a decir y qué vas a
si no entonces a mí no me vengan a decir
que el colegio
y el sistema educativo nos enseña
disciplina la disciplina se aprende
haciendo deporte y aprendiendo a comer
dos cosas que tampoco enseña el sistema
educativo
al final del día
lo que les enseñamos a nuestros hijos
es
la lucecita que tenemos para lograr un
mejor mundo
si esta generación no está preparada
para cambiar el mundo
todos nos habremos dado cuenta el
sistema educativo es un crimen gracias
[Aplausos]